ni libres ni justas así han calificado
varios países occidentales las
elecciones que tienen lugar en siria
este miércoles
pero como estado no nos importan
absoluto las declaraciones pero más
importante que lo que diga el gobierno
es lo que diga el pueblo voto algo más
de 12.000 colegios electorales en síria
para que voten en torno a 18 millones de
personas en 2011 la ciudad de homs se
alzó como bastión rebelde diez años
después con la destrucción de la guerra
un latente muchos de sus vecinos afirman
que votarán por bashar al asad y por
supuesto que votaremos por el al cien
por ciento con mi sangre estas
elecciones solamente tendrán lugar en
las zonas controladas por el régimen en
torno a dos tercios del país la
oposición en el exilio organizaciones
humanitarias y numerosos países han
acusado al asad de crímenes de guerra
limpiezas étnicas y desplazamientos
forzados muchos se fueron para nunca
volver ahora viven en campos de
refugiados como este del líbano
déjala que son estas elecciones él es
alguien que destruyó todo un país y lo
fragmento e hizo que destruyeran siria
mientras millones william no podemos
votar por el que no tiene un lugar en
nuestros corazones porque deberíamos
votar por él
google entró en estas elecciones asad
cuenta con dos oponentes abdulá salúm ex
viceministro de asuntos parlamentarios y
mahmoud haqmal marey dirigente de la
llamada oposición tolerada para algunos
una mera extensión del régimen con todo
este contexto nadie duda de la victoria
de al asad tampoco de que con ella no
llegara a la solución para siria las
próximas elecciones llegarán dentro de
siete años y ya se habla de una nueva
figura emergente para entonces la fed
hijo de bashar y esperanza de renovación
para el régimen sad